hello everyone it's really been a while
since I did my last video in the sorcery
series as a lot of you have mentioned
this in the comments section so I really
think you're gonna enjoy this one and
when I say in a long time I really mean
in a long time I have I really don't
remember when my last video in the
source every series was and I only made
seven of them so far so this is what
source here so sorcery is this video
number eight and before we check out
this game and it's quite quite a lovely
game about the photo challenge from the
last video of course it was Bobby
Fischer one look at his sweater I should
definitely give that away and for this
videos photo challenge I decided to take
advice from a subscriber meeting Rajesh
he's one of the first subscribers on my
channel also always one of the first
people who will join my livestream and
I'm pretty sure he's one of the first
subscribers on every channel as he
really really enjoys chess so it's um
this photo challenge is a bit different
but you know I hope I hope you will be
able to do it
so here it is I hope you all ready let's
go so who is this person now I don't
know how you could possibly know who
this is but okay I'm gonna trust me to
rush on this one so gonna check out the
comment section after after the video
and now about this game here we have a
game between Fernando Vizier Segovia
two times Spain champion and he
represented Spain plenty of times in the
Chess Olympiad he's a feed Emmaus Philly
master and he faces Michael Tao the
tournament was played in Las Palmas in
1977 but a very important thing we
should know we should mention is that
this is not the first game between
Fernando Segovia and Michael Tao the
first time two of them met was in palma
de mallorca in 1966 and this is the
final standings of that tournament
as you can see Michael towel won this
tournament with an amazing score of 12
out of 15 that 9 wins 0 losses and six
draws so definitely you know mopping the
floor with with a very strong field and
as you can see young Fernando this year
Segovia in last place with four and a
half out of 15 points
so and in that tournament tall defeated
Segovia in in 15 moves it was a very
short game I really have no idea what to
make of that game but I will add it in
the description below you know just if
you want to check it out
so about this game Fernando Bishop
Segovia gets another chance to play
against Michael towel and this game is
played 11 years after that 15 move win
by Michael Tao so let's check it out and
let's see why this game and makes it in
the sorcery series as I don't know if
you remember I mentioned in one of my
previous videos from the sorcery series
that I will not be using enemy cult all
games in my sorcery series because you
know so many of his games would would
definitely fit in here but there is a
reason why I'm using this one so let's
check it out Segovia is white and he
opens with d4 we have d6 d4 and d5 tall
goes for the English red defense and by
doing so he allows the D captures D
captures and queen cap person da so the
white could immediately go for a queen
exchange here and really hope for for
nothing in terms of advantage but
Segovia was also known to be quite a
creative player and we could definitely
say that this is an encounter of two
sorcerers so we have d5 advancing the
pawn Bishop to e7 Knight to c3
we have Knight to f6 and E 4 we have
castles Bishop to d3 Knight B to d7
vital Bishop to e3 c6 now challenging
the center h3 a6 preparing B 5/9 G 2 e 2
and C capture Sundy 5c capture some D 5
and now b5 we have castles tall brings
his knight over to c5 and hew leader
maybe captured a bishop on d3 or he will
force us to go via to capture his Knight
with the bishop of course Segovia isn't
interested in doing this as the dark
square Bishop is very powerful the light
square bishop not so much because he's
blocked by his own pawns so that's a
pretty you know nice example of bad
bishop good bishop so first night to g3
he allows Knight captures because
the night and see if I was a very strong
knight and the bishop and III not so
much but Todd was knighted the Bishop to
d7
he doesn't capture it and then he just
moves it you don't want to keep the
tension going too long before attacking
the knight Knight to e2 and now roped
the c8 we have f4 Bishop to b5 pinning
the night and now a four we have B 3 by
tau a capture some B 5 B captures on c2
Queen captures on c2 as segovia is not
afraid to put his Queen and c2 in front
of towels rook he captures on f4 rook
captures on f4 and this is the moment in
the game where it all happens here at
tal plays Knight to e6 by playing nine
three six tile is attacking Segovia's
rope on f4 but also he opened up an
attack from his rook to the Queen which
is something Segovia should have seen
when he played his Queen to c2 so
definitely tal will win the exchange
here but unfortunately for tal he will
not win the exchange he was hoping for
there is a different kind of exchange
here and Segovia didn't move his queen
but him he moved his Queen over to see
it and he played Queen captures on c8 so
a nice Queen sacrifice by Fernando
Vizier Segovia there's really no other
move other than the capture the Queen so
Queen captures and we have d captors on
e6 so what did we get here a rook and
the piece for a queen is it is it worth
it
well now place a captures on b5 if you
play F captures on e6 then you get B
captures on a6 and it's a very dangerous
passport that's gonna come to a 787 is
guarded by this Bishop on d3 then the
b-pawn is marching forward could be
could be very dangerous so instead at
all decides to capture on b5 and now we
have rook to a7 by Segovia attacking
Taos Bishop here and it's not very easy
to figure out a move here if you move
the bishop to them each 7 is coming
rook and Bishop or attack now you've
really done nothing here
and another thing after rook to a7 if
you try something like Queen to d8
defending then Knight the d4 is coming
with ideas of Knight to c6 would
attack on the Queen end on the bishop
and the bishop is already attacked by
the rook so black would be lost here and
even if you try to defend c6 than Knight
f5 is quite sufficient again there's a
double attack on the bishop there is no
way to move the bishop if you move it
then again ec7 is winning so not an easy
position to deal with for tau so top
plays F captures on e6 instead of moving
the bishop
we have rook captures on e7 and now rook
to f7 tall offers a trade of rooks rook
captures Kim captures and now rook back
to F - if the Queen comes you know for
example to c2 to try and infiltrate the
position then all of segovia species
will be there to help defend and if you
look at the position now as Segovia has
a bishop a knight and the rook for
Tallis Queen and also tile is up upon so
nothing you know it's pretty it's a
pretty fine position to play we have
Queen to see for battle King - H - I'm
getting his King to an even safer
location King to e8 unpinning as you
know the night couldn't move since rope
is on f2 and we have the 930 for King to
d7 now and rook to c2 attacking tiles
Queen Queen to b4 and now comes Knight
to c6 Queen to b3 attacking Segovia's
rook and c2 and now comes night the b8
check King t e8 and now comes rope to
see a check Tom moves the King King to
f7 and now Bishop to d4 at a defending
his B to pawn we have E 5 now rook to c7
check in to g6 and now bush of the c3
and here tall played h5 we have knife to
d7 by Segovia offering a trade of
knights and here Knight captures on d7
is definitely the best move and after
that it will be very hard for tau you
use his Queen to outmaneuver a rook a
bishop and the night but here tell of
course avoided this trade as if it would
be you know be too difficult opposition
to play and top late night to e8
avoiding the trade and also attacking
Segovia's rook but the problem is by
doing so tau allows a forced checkmate
in six
so you are Fernando Segovia in this
position feel free to pause the video
and beat Michael tall and you know take
your rightful place in this sorcery
series so I will give it a couple of
seconds if you want to decide you know
maybe if you wanna I try and solve this
puzzle so okay for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations so you are
quite the sorcerer and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show here
Knight to f8 check was played why is
this completely winning well you do have
a couple of choices you could go f6 you
could go h6 you could go g5 if you go
King to g5 then you get the shuttle D to
check and there's really nothing to do
here you can either lose the Queen with
Queen to e3 or you will move the king
and then Knight to f5 will be checkmate
another thing after knife to f8 check if
you play King to h6 then okay after
Bishop to d2 you do have this g5
blocking the bishop but now Knight to f5
check this will be checkmate or if you
prefer rook to h7 will also be a very
nice checkmate so after a night to f8
check towel decided to go King to f6 we
have Knight captures on h5 King to g5
and Bishop to d2 now also with check and
here came to h4 if he captures a knight
for example team captures on h5 then you
get g4 check King moves and now of
course Knight to g6 will be checkmate
so after Bishop to d2 check tall so that
you know there's no way of capturing the
knight and h5 so he played King to h4
but now comes g3 and it was in this
position and moved 39 that Matata
resigned the game why did he resign
oh well it doesn't really matter if you
captured the night we already shown this
variation g4 is coming and then there is
really nothing to do here we have to go
to h4 and the Knight to g6 will be
checkmate on the other hand even if you
don't even if you decide to maybe give
up the Queen it doesn't help you in any
way nightcap person g3 and now an
animove black place will be met with
Knight to g6 checkmate whatever you do
if you try something like g5 then both
Nagi six and rook h7 will be checkmate
so yeah after this G to remove my coat
I'll resign the game and after 11 years
since that loss in palma de mallorca
that tall one in 15 moves against
Fernando Segovia Fernando Segovia did
get his revenge and even though I
believe many players never actually
heard of Fernando Segovia by defeating
me at all in 1977 in Las Palmas
you know this game will surely go down
in history and hopefully you know many
many more people will know about
Fernando Vizier Segovia as this as like
I said I only made 7 videos so far for
my sorcery series this is video number 8
but out of those 8 videos that are now
available there are 2 of them are
actually by Fernando visitors to go via
so there is another beautiful game
played by him that is also in my sorcery
series also in the description below you
can check it out I will put a link to
the entire sorcery series so if you're
new to this channel you know feel free
to check out those games those games are
one of the craziest games you will ever
see and I believe that this game is you
know quite quite a nice game and that it
you know fits into my sorcery series and
especially since he defeated and none
other than Michael tall with with such
amazing play and you know brought his
game over to h4 so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and I would like to
thank Donna clitoris and close more
møller Nielsen for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting video
we'll see if I will continue with the
sorcery series or maybe maybe with
around 8 of the North 2018 LT box Norway
championship so thank you all and I will
see you soon